pant Aryan is American fiance Megan
Markel are revealing new details about
their upcoming royal wedding the
ceremony will take place at 12 noon on
may 19th at st. George's Chapel in
Windsor Jonathan Vigliotti is outside
Windsor Castle with how it will also
feature a two-mile carriage procession
Jonathan good morning good morning
Prince Harry has a special connection to
Windsor Castle he actually grew up going
to school just across the river and
would walk here after class to have tea
with his grandmother the Queen right now
the parade route is pretty quiet but
come May thousands of people will pack
your some waiting days camping out just
to catch a glimpse of the newlyweds
Windsor castles 700 year old seat
george's chapel has an equally long
history of royal weddings
most recently Prince Charles walked down
the HN aisle to get his marriage to
Camilla parker-bowles blessed in 2005 on
May 19th it will be Prince Harry and
Megan markle's turn the ceremony will be
officiated by the Archbishop of
Canterbury before an expected crowd of
800 friends and family the list is still
private but royal correspondent Roy
Anika has disappointing news for
President Trump we know they'll be about
800 guests probably the Obamas because
they have become very close friends of
Harry's through you know his work with
Invictus and their charitable foundation
not Donald Trump we here love and
marriage will then be followed by a
horse and carriage ride after leaving
st. George's Chapel the newlyweds will
travel along the town's Main Street then
down the so-called long walk before
arriving back at Windsor Castle giving
thousands of spectators a chance to see
the couple along the way they want to be
able to give the public a chance to
share their celebrations of them be part
of the day that was very very important
to Harry recommend the fest got engaged
how would they do that
it's a royal procession similar to the
wedding of Queen Elizabeth's youngest
son Prince Edward and Sophie Countess of
Wessex in 1999 even the carriage is
packed with history Prince William and
Kate rode in it after their 2011
ceremony as did Prince Charles and Lady
Diana before them and the royal couple
will be breaking with some tradition
they've chosen to have their wedding on
a Saturday instead of a Friday so that
more of the public can attend they also
won't be sharing a kiss on the balcony
of buckingham palace they will simply be
too busy attending to receptions John
Jonathan Vigliotti too busy for kissing
Windsor Castle